[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys it's justine and today we have
some more drone content for you i'm so
excited because
last year when i was reviewing the mavic
air we were still
in the middle of the pandemic no
actually it was the start it was
basically at the beginning
of when the whole world shut down and
since then i have flown that drone
quite a bit actually and it has been one
of my favorite drones and now they have
an
update to that drone this is the mavic
air
no just air 2 s seems as though they're
dropping the mavic
but i'm incredibly excited about this
one because this is basically a huge
update to that this now has
a one inch sensor i'm sure many of you
drone pilots are familiar with the mavic
2 pro which also has a one inch sensor
and shoots 4k
this little guy actually has a one inch
sensor as well but shoots
[Music]
5.4k
oh look at this accessories
and this is the fly more combo which
does come with batteries and a charger
and the controller
consider accessories box let's take a
little
a little look-see
i love that this comes with nd filters
already this is cool and it comes in
this nice little case
look at that extra little joysticks
extra adapters
usb c cable let's get the batteries
charged
propellers on firmware update i like
that each of these bags is labeled so it
shows you where the props will go
[Music]
oh
i really love this new master shots
feature this is kind of their next
evolution of quick shots which you
basically press a button and the drone
will automatically fly and get you some
really cool shots
this one's a little different because
it'll do 10 different shots all in one
sequence and then it will edit those
together to create a short cinematic
video after
i like this because a lot of times when
i'm out flying i might not have a lot of
time
so if i can just quickly send the drone
up choose the subject
it'll automatically shoot 10 different
shots for me i did trim these clips
slightly just for the sake of this video
but the final edit is a little bit
longer
[Music]
what are you seeing what are you seeing
okay so there's dolphins i'm filming
dolphins they're eating and playing and
doing dolphin things
[Music]
so
so i just brought my drone back jen and
i are out flying right now she's also
doing a video so i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check out
hers
and was trying to get some cool surfer
action but the waves are
very tiny so trying to get anybody doing
anything was kind of impossible but so
far i've been loving this drone
i feel like every time that jen and i
have been trying to go out and record
with it
it's been cloudy or it's been rainy so
i'm definitely looking forward to
testing this out more having this one
inch sensor has also been amazing i'm so
used to flying the pro version that does
have the one inch sensor
and now having that again you can
definitely tell with low light
situations
that the image is so much clearer being
able to quickly swap out those nd
filters was amazing when earlier it was
really bright outside
and overall honestly having an upgraded
obstacle avoidance
is really amazing not only for new drone
pilots
but even for experienced pilots as well
to be able to just fly through with
confidence because i've been flying a
lot of fpv recently
so kind of going back to the cinematic
style drone flying is very very
different anyway i will put a link in
the description if you guys want to
check out more info
about the dji air 2s i'm very excited
about this and i love all the things
that dji has been coming out with
recently so i definitely look forward to
seeing what you guys think of this
stay tuned for more drone footage in all
of my upcoming videos
i'll see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]
you